last lesson we introduced this idea
which gave us language to explain stuff
which we saw before we encountered
before but when you don't have language
for something it's very difficult to
understand how to fill out anything
about it ok so we introduced this and we
looked at all the pictures we looked at
some special cases that Illustrated
why it's useful category ok right now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna be a
little more formal about it ok I try as
much as possible not to start with
formal definitions because you get lost
in all the notation and that kind of
thing but now that you get the idea it's
time to get the umm symbols on the paper
so I want you to think back to this you
could probably find it in your paper but
I want us to write it up again anyway
because I'm finding you books because
it's worth seeing the parallel between
these things if I want continuity ok for
some function at a certain point okay if
I have a function and I'm thinking about
whether it has continuity or
differentiability at that point ok
because we've seen there are functions
which can be continuous a whole bunch of
places and differentiable a whole bunch
of places but they're just particular
critical points when you really have to
inspect these carefully formally
speaking what would it mean to be
continuous and I'll give you a clue it
starts with the limits ok anyone
remember yeah I mean soon ah very good
ok so here's what's happening we want to
think about this certain point we want
to get closer and closer that's what the
limits are back to that point but thank
you Doris
we need to look carefully at what
happens from one direction versus the
other right
so a plus means come from higher values
that's from the right and I want to know
what's happening to f of X ok I want
that to be doing exactly the same thing
as what happens if I approach but from
the opposite direction so a with the
minus means come from lower values come
from below so that's from left to right
okay
we want to see what's happening f of X
from that direction and both of those
should also be equal to 1/3 feet do you
remember
f of a good F of a because just really
quickly if you remember don't write this
just remember it okay if you think of a
simple function like this guy what on x
squared okay you don't need to put any
pen to paper to know that there's going
to be a discontinuity
at at x equals zero because he's on the
denominator but if you recall what this
looks like is something like this now as
you approach 0 from the left and from
the right you're going up here what are
you approaching what values you
approaching you're going up to positive
infinity right so these two are equal
for this case but because they're not
equal to this because this doesn't exist
at 0 it's not continuous ok right now
the great thing about having this formal
definition here is because the
definition of for differentiability is
almost identical but it's about the
derivative right so instead of this
limit it's going to be the limit as X
approaches a from above not of F the
function itself but I'm interested in
the derivative f duck okay and what I
want that to be equal to is what's
happening to the derivative if I'm
approaching from the other direction
okay that's going to be
as well okay now you can also put f dash
a over here but as you see in a second
when you get this and it's interesting
like saying this piecemeal function
we're about to look at this becomes less
important really establishing this
that's all you need right for
establishing that it's not true that's
all you need okay